after what feels like 84 years we the
public have finally gotten our hands on
the beta to the fabled mysterious and at
times seemingly non-existent sequel
to overwatch suffice it to say save a
few new maps a new game mode a few
reworks the shift to 5v5 and an engine
overhaul
it feels a hell of a lot like the first
overwatch
the question
is whether that's a bad thing
[Music]
okay so before we sojourn slide our way
into this video i must ask that you like
subscribe and turn on notifications
i'm sorry i just i i you think i like
these puns any more than you do all
right like you think i feel good about
myself like they just they make me do
them all right and you just you run out
of ideas and you just gotta come up with
something
first things first let's get the shock
value stuff out of the way i dmitri am
in fact an avid overwatch player yes i
am of sound mind and
wrist no i did not lose a bet i love
overwatch and up until the beta for the
sequel came out i played the original
about three to four times a week i know
i know but dimitri you are a cs go siege
elitist how could you possibly defile
the sanctity of aiming by willfully
engaging in such silly shield-oriented
tomfoolery
honestly
i'm as surprised as you are it's an
infuriating game that's riddled with
problems imbalanced as hell and you can
rest assured i hate it dearly
but i also love it because it's
exhilarating and fun and there's
there's just nothing quite like it so
now that that is out of the way
let's talk about the beta now i do want
to make the proviso that this is really
more of a first impressions type video
from a seasoned overwatch one player and
not a comprehensive walkthrough i like
most of you only got access to the beta
on wednesday night and put in like five
six hours of play at most over the last
two days
it's also just a question of time if i
was to go through every single hero or
ability rework this video would be like
40 minutes so we're just gonna talk in
broad strokes let's start with a
fastball down the middle the new hero
soju as i'm sure you've all been made
aware sojourn is a slick slidey apex
legend style dps whose kit aside from
including an aoe snare revolves almost
entirely around her weapon her left
click offers a fully automatic spray
that starts off as a laser beam and
slowly becomes more unwieldy the longer
you hold it inflicting damage with said
left click charges her right click which
fires an instant railgun-esque hit scan
ray her alt gives you a handful of said
rays she seems
okay decent but kind of situational
although to be honest i'm not really the
right guy to ask since i lowkey kind of
hate dps and find all the heroes in that
role to be
super
super boring next the new maps slash
gamemode as of right now there are four
new maps circuit royale and midtown
which are escort and hybrid respectively
and two push maps set in toronto and
rome what is a push you ask
well that is the new game mode think
escort but with a healthy dose of
tug-of-war both teams fight over a
neutral robot who once captured pushes
each team's respective wall thingy in
whichever direction they're fighting
towards the team who gains the most
ground by rounds and wins personally i
think it's really cool it's basically a
scrappier more dynamic escort that kind
of gets rid of these
static shield supported pirate shippy
strats since you can't actually set up
on top of the robot okay now for the
real stuff the shift to 5v5 and the
reworks they're sort of intertwined for
those who've been living under a rock
overwatch's multiplayer is now 5 vs 5 as
opposed to 6 vs 6. they literally
removed an entire tank slot so how does
it feel
well as a tank main i can tell you it
feels
weird as it turns out having only one
tank on the board
changes
everything because there are no longer
tank duos you don't play say reinhard as
often or as aggressively as you used to
since he doesn't have a zarya anymore
likewise you don't play zarya as
passively since it's no longer her job
to babysit and enable a main tank this
is one of those things that i just
haven't really developed a full opinion
on yet since i just haven't played
enough but as an off tank main who plays
hogg and zarya primarily i can tell you
that it feels both really hard
and really freeing depending on the
matchup running hog into a non-shield
tank for instance felt like a huge buff
the thing is because i no longer have a
shield tank of my own to block
projectiles and abilities like ante
running up against zen and anna felt
even more oppressive than it did in the
original overwatch what's more there are
a few key reworks that along with the
slot removal make playing tank
way different some are small like how
rein now gets two fire strike charges or
how zarya has two bubble charges that
allow her to use either two personals or
externals in succession others are
bigger orisa for instance no longer has
a shield and is sort of a deflective
initiator whose kit actually bears
traces of resemblance to jax's in league
of legends doomfist has also been
reworked into a slightly more defensive
hero and more importantly has formally
been classified as a tank as opposed to
the absurdly overtuned tank-like dps he
was in the original overwatch don't get
me wrong he's still good his right click
is just no longer a slightly better
version of a reinhardt to all of the
dirty shameless doomfist spammers
transitioning over from the original
overwatch
i want you to know that i mean this
so sincerely like from the bottom of my
heart
get absolutely
as for the rest of the reworks i'm not
gonna dive too deeply into them since to
be honest i just haven't really had a
chance to experiment with all of them
yet but aside from full radical reworks
like bastion or to a slightly lesser
degree sombra
the general takeaway is that the devs
wanted to lessen the frequency and
efficacy of crowd control the best
example of this is cassidy's stun
grenade which is now a homing sticky
grenade that well doesn't stun it just
does damage heroes have also been
granted role specific passives tanks get
reduced knockback and less all-charge
gains from healing and damage dps get a
movement speed boost and supports get
passive healing what this means is that
we now have a 5v5 overwatch with fewer
shields inherent passives and a lot less
crowd control now how different of a
game is that from the original
more than you probably think i know
there's a lot of people out there
memeing about how overwatch 2 is just
overwatch one without any real
differences
but that's just not true at all for
starters the engine overhaul is really
noticeable in a really good way the
weapons feel way crispier and cleaner
the physics are a lot more consistent
and i can tell you as a hog main that
the physics in overwatch one left
a lot to be desired
it also feels as if the weapons just hit
harder i honestly don't know if it's
just because there are fewer shields and
because healing isn't as strong or if
they actually upped the damage but you
can pepper a pharah in the sky and
actually notice how much more damage
he's doing the game feels a lot more
like a shooter now and
i think that's a good thing now is it a
whole new video game
no it's a new overwatch which is
always what it was going to be the
people out there who are complaining
that this isn't new enough probably
didn't spend a lot of time playing the
original or were just horribly jaded by
it and in all honesty we're probably
just expecting this to be something that
was never going to be but for people who
do play a lot of overwatch the changes
are
gargantuan
just like 1.6 and global offensive were
wildly different games to people who
play a lot of counter-strike so is
blizzard's long-awaited sequel an
absolute game changer for die hards out
there now all of that being said i do
think it is fair to say that blizzard
kept things somewhat tame with the beta
and that more changes are probably
slated to come down the pike depending
on what kind of feedback creators and
competitors have to offer about the
existing changes so after like two days
of play
what's the verdict is dimitri a fan of
the overwatch 2 beta
he is i think that this sequel could not
only freshen up the game but
remedy a lot of the issues that no
amount of buffing and nerfing and
[ __ ] roll locking ever could now do i
wish that hook could pierce genji
deflect or that vape could purge ante or
that blizzard would be a little more
liberal with implementing some of the
changes from the experimental server
yes i do but i also recognize that these
things take time
and while i'm not willing to wait
forever i am willing to see where this
ship takes us because
i am having a lot yes a lot of fun
trying out stuff in this beta and from
what i can gather
everybody else is too
i am having a lot yes a lot of fun
trying out stuff in the beta and from
what i can gather
everybody else oh
i choked it right on the finish line and
from what i can gather
everybody else oh my god i can't say
everybody else yes a lot of fun trying
out stuff in this beta and from what i
can gather
everybody i can't say it i don't know
why i can't say everybody else is too